when your brain right now is talking is
it doing next word prediction
or is it doing something more
interesting well definitely some kind of
a generative model that's a gpt-like and
prompted by you
um yeah so you're giving a prompt and
I'm kind of like responding to it in a
generative way and by yourself perhaps a
little bit like are you adding extra
prompts from your own memory inside your
head
automatically feels like you're
referencing some kind of a declarative
structure of like memory and so on and
then uh you're putting that together
with your prompt and giving away some
messages like how much of what you just
said has been said by you before
uh nothing basically right no but if you
actually look at all the words you've
ever said in your life and you do a
search you'll probably said a lot of the
same words in the same order before yeah
it could be I mean I'm using phrases
that are common Etc but I'm remixing it
into a pretty uh sort of unique sentence
at the end of the day but you're right
definitely there's like a ton of
remixing what you didn't you it's like
Magnus Carlsen said uh I'm I'm rated
2900 whatever which is pretty decent I
think you're talking very uh you're not
giving enough credit to neural Nets here
why do they seem to
what's your best intuition
about this emergent Behavior I mean it's
kind of interesting because I'm
simultaneously underselling them but I
also feel like there's an element to
which I'm over like it's actually kind
of incredible that you can get so much
emergent magical Behavior out of them
despite them being so simple
mathematically so I think those are kind
of like two surprising statements that
are kind of just juxtaposed together
and I think basically what it is is we
are actually fairly good at optimizing
these neural Nets and when you give them
a hard enough problem they are forced to
learn very interesting Solutions in the
optimization and those solution
basically have these immersion
properties that are very interesting
there's wisdom and knowledge
in the knobs
and so what's this representation that's
in the knobs does it make sense to you
intuitively the large number of knobs
can hold the representation that
captures some deep wisdom about the data
it has looked at
it's a lot of knobs it's a lot of knobs
and somehow you know so speaking
concretely
um one of the neural Nets that people
are very excited about right now are are
gpts which are basically just next word
prediction networks so you consume a
sequence of words from the internet and
you try to predict the next word and uh
once you train these on a large enough
data set
um they you can basically prompt these
neural Nets in arbitrary ways and you
can ask them to solve problems and they
will so you can just tell them you can
you can make it look like you're trying
to um
solve some kind of a mathematical
problem and they will continue what they
think is the solution based on what
they've seen on the internet and very
often those Solutions look very
remarkably consistent look correct
potentially